نجوان يبدو ان هناك انفجارا ضخما نرى
اعمده كبيره للدخان تتصاعد في المناطق
المطله على غلاف غزه ما الذي
يجري نعم بالفعل في الدقيقه الاخيره سمعنا
ضوي انفجار كبير ياتي من هذه المنطقه وسط
قطاع غزه تحديدا منطقه مخيمات الوسط يبدو
بان هذا الانفجار تحديدا في مخيم البريج
الان اي غير واضح بعد فيما اذا كانت هذه
غاره جويه استهدفت هذا الموقع ام انها
عمليات تفجير لقوات الاحتلال لاحد المباني
او ال المنشات لكن في نفس الوقت هذا تزامن
مع قصف مدفعي ايضا من هذه المواقع في غلاف
غزه استهدف مناطق الوسط ولكن ايضا الاطراف
الشماليه والشرقيه لمدينه غزه هذا
القصف المدفعي متواصل ودوي الانفجارات
ايضا متواصل مياده في بعض الاحيان يكون
ناجما عن تفجيرات تجريها وحده ال الهندسه
او سلاح الهندسه التابع لجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ل مبان سكنيه لمنشات او في بعض
الاحيان وفقا لبياناته يتحدث عن انه يقوم
بعمليات تفجير لبنى تحتيه تتعلق بالانفاق
الاستراتيجيه او الانفاق
الهجوميه التابعه لحركات المقاومه
الفلسطينيه تحديدا لحركه حماس عمليا
عمليات القصف هذه ايه لا تتوقف على
الاطلاق القصف المدفعي تح تحديدا وهناك
تحيق في الجو لمروحيات عسكريه اي من طراز
اباتشي بعد بين الحين والاخر نسمع
اشتباكات بالرشاشات الثقيله تشارك فيها
هذه المروحيات بالاضافه الى تحليق
للمسيرات
والطيران الحربي المتواصل الجيش
الاسرائيلي يركز عملياته وفقا لبياناته
ووفقا لتصريحات المسؤولين الامنيين في
الجانب الاسرائيلي على منطقه خان يونس في
الجنوب ومحيط خان يونس ويوم امس كان وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي يف جالانت قد قال بانه
لا حسم للمعركه بدون تحقيق انتصار للجانب
الاسرائيلي ت وان العمليات تحديدا في
منطقه خان يونس ست ستتواصل عفوا بمعزل عما
يحدث في مناطق اخرى فيما اذا كان الجيش
الاسرائيلي بدا ينتقل الى المرحله الثالثه
تحديدا في منطقه الشمال واعاده انتشار
لقواته وسحب قواته من الاحياء والبلدات
الشماليه في قطاع غزه الا انه في منطقه
خان يونس يواصل هذه العمليات وفقا لما
قاله يواف جلنت يوم امس خلال زياره تفقديه
للقوات في داخل غزه صباح هذا اليوم دوت
صافرات الانذار في منطقه غلاف غزه تحديدا
في منطقه نتيف عسرا وفي يد مردخاي وايضا
الليله الماضيه مباشره بعد عمليه الاغتيال
التي طالت القياده في حركه حماس الشيخ
الشهيد صالح العاروري في بيروت كانت قد
دوت ايضا صافرات الانذار الليله الماضيه
في منطقه كيسوفيم شرق قطاع غزه هناك خشم
او تقديرات لدى الاجهزه الامنيه بان الرد
من حركه حماس سياتي اما من غزه او من
مناطق اخرى لكن هناك تحس يعني رفع للحاله
التاهب وهناك تحسب لان تكون هناك عمليات
حتى على صعيد ربما الاسرى الاسرائيليين
المحتجزين في غزه وهذا يرفع حاله القلق
والتوتر والخشيه لدى عائلاتهم تحديدا
مياده شكرا جزيلا لك من غلاف غزه مراسله
الجزيره نجوان سمري